you know I love relish there's always
that odd jar of odd that condiment that
odd condiment that's sitting off to the
side that green some people don't even
know what relish is some people see a
thing a relish are like damn what is it
it looks like a salad maybe had a heart
attack or got electrocuted and that's
relish an relishes you know it's
everything kind of it's almost like it's
like being in love when you're young
it's romantic and it's sweet and it's
spicy and relishes like kind of soft and
it's wet but it's you know trying to
hold itself together and it it doesn't
know what it is sometimes is it a
vegetable is it uh is it a sauce is it a
you know what is it and you can see
relish sometimes you can almost envision
the bottle or the little jar
you know relish comes in a little jar a
little glass cage really and you can
almost if you think about relish you
could see it just one you could see it
maybe at a therapist's office sitting on
accounts just kind of wondering what it
is because the other condiments the
other they're very clear it's ketchup
you know this is tomatoes and this is a
a specific sauce and that must hard boy
you hit that you know you see a man a
strong man to heart but then you got
relish it's got a spoon out of it
sometimes coming out the jar the lid is
missing like where's the lid who-who
gonna you know how they gonna contain
this relish if they need to and that's
sometimes what I feel like you know I
feel like sometimes I just feel like
relish man I just feel like that like
this strange condiment that that's just
kind of out in the world
I feel like man you know everybody else
is kind of ketchup and mustard and and
I'm not or everybody else's cheese or
everybody else's this or that and I'm
not an relish doesn't get the same
accolades as some of these other arm you
know some of these condiments have
better public relations they have better
advertising and all of that you know
that must start baby you get a that
strong yellow that strike that [ __ ] that
makes you you know a baby can't handle
it
dude you put about an 11th of an ounce
of mustard into a baby's mouth son
they'll grow up fast and against their
will they do not like it you know it's
it's not for a child of mustard
but that relish baby that's what that's
what that that's that's the condiment
that really relates to me is relish
you know it's off to the side it's got a
spoon in it people know what it is it
looks like a salad maybe they got in a
fight with you know with something it
looks like somebody just you know uh it
looked like maybe a gardener just had
his sinuses rinsed out you know somebody
you know hit an epi pot into a gardener
and just rinsed him out and and it has
that kind of vibe to it you're like damn
what happened here look like mr.
McGregor just cleared his throat but
that relish you don't know what it is is
it a salad is it a salsa is as sweet as
a spicy is a sweeter spicy that's my
riff raff Norris impersonation you don't
know what it is that relish it's off to
the side sometimes it as a spoon and
it's something that has nothing don't
have a lid on the jar you just don't
know what it is it's kind of like Mother
Nature I made like a dirty frosting
and you know and I can relate to that
relative a nights how I feel sometimes I
just feel like this little side item you
know I'm not one of these main events
I'm not I'm not that ketchup I'm not
that that must Hardman I feel like just
more of a relish sometimes hey you're a
CEO this is Ginny from Atlanta what's up
Kenny from that ATL the Matlin's boy
let's get it I know I listen to your
podcast most recent podcast about Revis
and I had look he took my relish yeah
idea or maybe was an epiphany I was
thinking it's really just okay pickle
you know is it that homoerotic bad boy
it's a good question is relish that's a
gay pickle and you might be on to
something
you know epiphany Kenny out here just
throwing those forethought javelins at
us and they're hitting us you might be
on to something he's relish a gay pickle
relish is something it definitely seems
like you know it's almost like a salad
set [ __ ] it let's be jello so there's
definitely something going on there I
think I think it would test positive for
some different types of stuff you know
um so I think there's there's something
in the water right there you got it you
got you got a good uh you got a good
good idea there Epiphany Kenny
Wow you know what's crazy as my sister
can't even read but what does it have to
do with us right now
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one